hey what's up folks samuel lee's here
absolutely exhausted been a crazy last
couple of weeks and i've just done
the most ridiculous challenge that i've
ever done which is strip myself of
everything i often say this on stage
when i'm speaking on stage i say you
could strip me naked and leave me in any
random city and within days i'd be
making good money through property and i
decided to really put that to the test
so i got dumped in london i knew it was
gonna be a start all over again i knew
it was gonna be like a financial freedom
challenge type thing but my team the
producers um put together the rules
and when i got dumped in london they
took away my wallet fair enough my car
keys fair enough my mobile phone
things are gonna get tough and
my clothes so i was literally dumped in
london with nothing
no clothes not a pot to piss in and had
to start over again from scratch and to
be honest it's probably been the hardest
thing i ever had to do it was completely
embarrassing and not just the clothes
but also when i managed to finally get
some clothes to cover up then just get
making my first pound is the hardest
pound and then turning that pound into
you know 30 pounds and building my way
up it was just absolutely ridiculous but
i tell you something if you are
skeptical that you can make money
starting with nothing if you think that
it takes money to make money then you
definitely need to check this out it's
live it's over at my um my new channel
on undercover millionaire so i'll leave
a link in the description where you can
check it out but what i'll say is this
it was the hardest thing i've ever done
but the most rewarding at times i was
busking in the streets trying to make a
few pounds it was really really really
hard so check it out i'll leave a link
in the description and you'll get to see
me literally starting out all over again
from scratch with no money at all with
no mobile phone with no internet and
with no clothes enjoy link in
description as of this moment you have
been stripped of your old identity and
your new alias is now john smith hand
over all personal items including your
phone money and clothes
best of luck your time starts now
[Music]
challenge accepted
[Music]
i'm really sorry